you um I feel like you guys did such a
great job of branding cuz I remember all
like like there was like the series of
albums where all of the covers were very
similar then you'd open the book and the
CDs were all very Sim like you guys had
like very dope branding like every album
had a different clown and then the
Jersey would go with it or the shirt who
cuz I I do feel like um you know on the
marketing side you guys were amazing who
was kind of the brainchild behind like
some of the early like [__] that you
guys would come up with May whether it
be like hey we got to make sure this
line of albums are consistent with the
art and the CDs and they all kind of go
together I Know This Much doing that
[__] back then um is the reason we still
move physical units today yeah you know
what I'm say people it's their
collector's yeah it's like people people
always are going to wonder what you're
going to do you know like we'll put like
a [__] pair of 3D glasses in there
and and put all kind of crazy [__] in
there and we put a booklet with like
mazes and funny I remember that I
remember yeah you guys had the mazes on
the front yeah yeah and then like you
could pull [__] out and make a piece of
dice and you know what I mean it's just
cool like uh you know what I'm saying
but yeah we we include we do [__] like
that and try to do really good packaging
and um to our benef that comes from back
in the day though any you know I don't
know I don't know where that comes from
we are that's just always done it like
that you know you guys just always kind
of had a knack for like I think so yeah
that's the best way of putting a knack
can you give me the origins of the
hatchet man logo yeah man that everyone
has tattooed in the very beginning me
and Joey me and Shaggy he's like um we
had two we had two ideas for the label
name one was one was a great name mad
paper boy right and and it was going to
be a guy on a bike
with a with a um a [__] newspaper
like like like the game and we wanted to
call it back then this is before paper
was known as money though because um
there was a [__] paper boy used to
come through looking like [__] the
Napoleon Dynamite kind of right and and
[__] throwing papers everywhere and
um he was our boy we just love to see
him so we were like how about mad paper
bo uh records and um I thought that
would have been cool the other one was
Psychopathic you know it's same idea but
now just a guy with a instead of a paper
he's got the uh the um hatchet man you
know what I mean it's crazy because I
mean thousands upon thousands of people
have tattoos of you guys [__] do you
remember the year that you first noticed
like cuz that's got to when artists get
like have fans that are that dedicated
it's I I can only imagine how trippy
it's got to be when it first happens
like yo this guy's got us tattooed on
him like do you remember like when you
guys first started to notice that you're
guys' fans were that dedicated cuz
that's a level of commitment that man
what what what do you say to a ninja
that walks up to you pulls his shirt off
and his entire back you know is all
[__] in his whole body sometimes you
know what I mean what do you say right
how do you even react to that that's
just something it it it it's like the
type of person I am I it makes me
uncomfortable
a ping of um a ping of uh hurt you know
what I mean or whatever the [__] term is
because I don't know how the [__] to you
know respond to that it's so stunning
are you are you used to it yet cuz at
this point we're talking I'm not I'll
never be used to that and I'll never
understand it you know um I don't want
to say the wrong thing I love the the
[__] devotion and dedication you get
what I'm saying but me I I you know I I
I would um
one thing I don't like doing I'm not I
don't like signing my name for an
autograph because they because they'll
get a tattooed on a hottie right I don't
want that I'm like man if you were my
woman I don't want that Ninja's name
yeah I don't want I don't to I don't
want to ruin your love life 5 years from
now I'm like no I I don't I'm not used
especially I'm you know I'm not going to
do it to any I don't like that you know
what I'm saying we signning trying to
get a tattoo [__] no you you know but uh
if if if some if a dude wants that
whatever man I I just I just don't give
a [__] myself I don't give a [__] about
an autograph right I don't have no
autograph I don't have any pictures of
me and anybody I don't give a [__] you
know what I mean n yeah I can imagine
bro the only person that ever um the
only person that ever made me and uh
Shaggy nervous to me was when we met
Vince McMahon hey that had to be sick
Bro our [__] mouths dried out like we
were both like and he was like hey who
who won the Grim Tim contest you know
and that was like a contest we were
having back then you know and we just
looked at